let's just jump right into that you
played a game that a lot of people want
to play it's not every once and it feels
like it's been coming after ya look at
least twice so uncharted 4 it's like
finally coming out next month and I got
to play it last week how much did you
get to play I'd like to play one mission
so it was like 20 25 minutes worth of
gameplay um but it showed off sort of
various aspects of the game it was kind
of a nice little just um portion of the
game that showed off each of the you
know individual aspects that's going to
play a larger role in the overall
experience so there was some traversal
some exploration a lot of like driving
around a four-by-four run then like a
nice combat section at the end so a
little taste of everything the game has
to offer cool so it was that the part
that they've just released the gameplay
for this week with the sort of the Jeep
and the mountain in the background
exactly so I got to replay that myself
last week and captured some footage so
the footage that we have up on our site
currently half of it stuff that I
captured in half it is from the official
footage that they released okay um it's
a pretty long demo that they release
actually at 16 minutes yeah yeah I took
a little longer because I just kind of
like export around like a lot of that
footage kind of cuts out the optional
side areas that they just kind of like
breeze past because I guess they want
you to find them for yourself when you
play the game but yeah the game clearly
has more exploration now there's just
like little side pockets and journal
entries you can pick up and you know
there are the same kind of collectibles
that have always existed in the
franchise but there's kind of more like
story content to discover on the side
now I mean like the way I framed my
whole preview for what I played last
week was how the last of us has
influenced uncharted and for me one of
the most obvious ways is the way that
uncharted now treats sort of the quieter
moments in between combat which have
sort of always been there but were never
the focus it was sort of like like oh
yeah okay then this thing happens and
let's get on to the next set piece now
it's they really kind of like embrace
those portions and almost expand them
and they do that in a gameplay way by
allowing to explore more but they also
use those moments to like fill in
characters back stories and just have
fun kind of bantering and it allows you
to connect with the characters in a
human way because it's not just like
gunfire all the time they'll be talking
about why they're there and sort of
their relationship and then just idle
chatter as well just kind of joking
around it makes you feel very like they
feel more familiar it feels like you're
more at home with these characters so
it's kind of cool the way that they've
done that as scroll back and the shot
says the child are back and forth in the
video for this
was so good the amount of like
incidental dialog they seem to have in
this game is like almost like I don't
trust it until I see the full game
because they were just chit-chatting
like there was one part in the demo
where you drove through a waterfall and
like Sully gives out to you because it's
like he you've just got like got me you
could've give me warning before you did
that there were quite a few moments like
that including several that do not
appear anywhere in the footage that's
online which the stuff that I happen to
see during my playthrough cool so there
ya there I mean they clearly have
written a great deal of dialogue and
other types of character interactions
that you know it there's a good chance
you will not see all of them because
they are sort of ambient they just occur
naturally as you play and you might not
do a thing that triggers a particular
conversation and also I've noticed that
Im for example if two characters are
conversing and I stopped the Jeep and
got out went to explore something they
would acknowledge that I was stopping
and getting out they'd be like okay I
guess you're not interested like just
give Drake a hard time and then when I
got back into the Jeep the conversation
would continue they'd be like so anyway
and then just pick up where the converse
all there's a pretty sophisticated kind
of conversation system happening in the
background that again to me feels like
it's borrowed from last of us because
there were a lot of those moments of
like Joel and Ellie just kind of walking
somewhere and using those communauté
commuter moments as an opportunity for
storytelling so it's interesting that
they have really kind of leaned into
that and and at least in the portion
that I played did a really excellent job
of fleshing that kind of stuff out and
yeah it'll be interesting to see if they
can keep that up for the whole
experience but I mean it's it's naughty
dog man if there's a developer I have
faith in to accomplish this they're
probably the team to do it yeah it
sounds like one of those games as
perfect for those old like sound test
things in like the menu of the game
where you can cycle through and play all
the sound effects yeah just like on a
Genesis car so yeah Streets of Rage is
no wonder yeah Peter yeah except they
used to do that when there was like 12
sounds in the game right more that
what's the yet Peter will know this like
what was the size of like the sake of
sound file where like you started your
Genesis and it goes like that apparently
took up a huge amount of space on every
card really had a thing yeah that's what
I've heard that like that audio file on
its own was often as big as the game
that was on the cartridge I requested
yeah well I think I can't I can't verify
can I be right I'm sorry to put you on
the spot no nose like our resident
historian I assume that like if anybody
will do some research for that and
exercise I haven't heard about that and
yet might know a met Phyllis in this is
a type swear this is the thing with we
should fill them in on uncharted though
more importantly I want to ask another
question about this which is I guess
like you talk about your last of us sort
of you know comparison which is you know
it's a sort of an easy comparison make
because that's what they just made and
all this recent game and also it was a
sort of like a tonal shift from the for
what we see when I chatted series which
are games where you're basically killing
loads and loads and loads of people and
one of the things in the last of us
which they tried to like delicately
balanced was you know how horrible it is
the joel has to murder or an ally has to
have to murder all these people and
which was it's like a different
balancing act like some games with them
worse than others like BioShock Infinite
was one of those games it just felt like
two different games with the story in
the combat like is there an element of
that in here where like they're fleshing
out these characters and are having this
loved it road trip and then there again
murdering like 15 20 20 people at a base
the mean there's there's definitely
still a disconnect as there is in many
shooters where you're you know killing
an inordinate number of people i mean i
think that was part of what allowed it
to feel kind of realistic in the last
was the the number of enemies you were
killing was substantially lower so in
addition to going out of their way to
justify like here's why you have like
this is you're fighting for survival
thank you really like they will murder
you you have to kill them and really you
know enforces that idea but also there
were fewer people to kill so it felt
believable uncharted still killing a ton
of dudes like the combat section at the
end there were at least a dozen guys
that you just kind of gun down and then
Drake is immediately they'll like
quickie and happy again so there is a
disconnect but I mean like that that's
always been there and I feel like that's
true of a lot of shooters it's it's an
interesting topic that's worth exploring
but I don't know that it's like a huge
problem for uncharted it still has the
same tone it's not like it's become a
drastically more dramatic game as a
result of having been influenced by the
last of us it the tone feels very much
in line with the rest of the series it's
you know it's a PO pee action experience
there's like explosions and like funny
jokes things like that Oh funny are they
actually funny jokes so far yeah I
laughed a couple of times during the
game
I think I want anyway it was like Saudi
giving out about the winch the whole way
through the process and eventually they
have to use the winch because he get to
pay more to get the car with the winch
and it was like we're never gonna use it
and then eventually they use it means
like that's only one that's like what
one time we've used it like but into a
krav the winch auto problem with paying
more for the winch yes I mean there's
nothing that's like laugh out loud
hilarious because it's really not that
kind of game but it's the kind of stuff
that like makes you relate to the
characters you kind of smile and you
know it there's this sense of
camaraderie among them that you know at
least you won me over at least in the
same way that previous android games
have looks gorgeous too it is a very
good-looking game yes uh I don't know
that it's like it's the best looking
game of all time but it's yeah it's the
the step up from uncharted 3 which
obviously was a PlayStation 3 game very
noticeable this is a gorgeous game
especially relative to previous
franchise entries so I think players can
at least look forward to it being a very
good looking game if nothing else and
these I guess base elements base
invasion elements at the end of it where
you there are all these you know this is
essentially an outpost with a bunch of
dudes in it and you sort of have to take
them up take them on like hard to
separate that from games that have come
out in the past couple of years
especially like last year with Metal
Gear Solid in terms of oh I wonder how
I'll be able to tackle this was their
elements of stealth and obviously did
they work well like once you're seeing
is it just like everyone knows you're
there like how to how does it work yeah
it is basically like once you've been
detected like that's it like all hell
breaks loose or so that you can do about
it you're now in a firefight but yeah
there are total Metal Gear vibes to the
way that combat works now it's not
drastically different from the way that
it worked in previous entries but now
there is an extra layer of stealth on
top that's basically optional I mean if
you want to just charge in you can go
ahead and drive your four by four
straight in the battle and like not care
but there are now tools so that's
players can utilize to sort of plan
their attack a little more thoroughly or
like you find a way to give themselves
the upper hand so like just to give you
a quick overview there are now this dumb
indicators above enemies heads let you
know if they've noticed you it'll start
to fill up if you're sort of in their
sight line and once it turns yellow
they'll start searching for you actively
in a sort of Assassin's Creed kind of
way once they spot you then that's when
combat starts but if they're just sort
of yellow
and they're kind of suspicious you can
still like hide or you can stealth take
them out before they notify everybody
else that hey Drake's here let's go kill
them and stuff so you do have the option
to take a more stealthy approach this
time again you don't have to but it's
kind of cool that they have at least
equipped players who want to play that
way with the tools to do it and Heather
the Jeep feel actually considering it
looks like we've seen two sort of long
demos in both of them at a lot of
driving in it yeah it is interesting
that they've really committed to the
Jeep but it handles well again it just
feels kind of like an opportunity for
them to you know imbue the game with a
little more storytelling and just give
you kind of something else to do when
you're traversing between combat moments
and and it allows for more free
exploration I mean they've talked a lot
about how this is the largest uncharted
both in terms of the length of the game
but also in terms of the size of the
environments and at least in my
experience that has proven true like the
the hills of Madagascar that I was
driving through we're definitely
definitely a very substantial area they
refer to it as wide linear so it is
funneling you in a particular direction
well I loves to explore as you're
heading in that direction so I I
absolutely share Peters eye roll but it
did it did prove true to me at least
that there was a lot of area that you
could potentially explore Peter is now
making faces the podcast people are
missing out a lot of others excellent
expressions of disdain everyone's
missing out what's your pointing the
camera at me what's your favorite wide
linear game of 2050 Oh knock wanna break
wanna break yeah oh yeah well get to
that actually in a little bit final
thoughts I guess on its god it's coming
at May tenth on the PlayStation 4 it's
it's finally happening I guess the last
thing I'll say is that I also got a
chance to interview Neil druckmann right
who is both director creator of creative
lead on last of us in the creative
director on uncharted 4 and just talking
to him gives me a lot of faith in the
game I really like his very thoughtful
approach to making games he very much
has a storyteller's mind and for me
that's really important i know a lot of
gamers don't really care about story
they will skip cutscenes in whatever but
i really like feeling like the the
gameplay as a purpose really i know what
i'm doing and i have an incentive or you
know being like hey
flip the power switches and restore
power to the gate is not nearly as
exciting as hey this character that you
care about and are invested in is going
to die unless you do something go do it
that to me makes it game much more
enjoyable so his approach very much
seems to cater to that type of game and
so yeah just having an opportunity to
talk to him about all that stuff give me
give me a lot of faith in the project
and yeah just like where his head's at
although people should definitely go
check out that interview if they haven't
already it's up on the site you thank
you so much god are you laughing about
wide linear again no it likes for his
heads and I was like on top of his
shoulders that's just because you've
been playing virtual reality for the
past week your head has been separated
for all I know you know what it is a
funny phrase though sure you're not
wrong thanks so much for going on yes
all about it that's good it sounds like
I was kind of wondering if there might
be some like red flags waved at this one
cuz like it's it's like true well
trodden grand now for the series but it
sounds like it's it's interesting they I
mean in talking to to the developers
that I talked to other developers
besides Neil druckmann as well but they
seem fully aware that like yeah this is
the fourth installment and we needed to
like do something different and kind of
go bigger and really give this series
the send-off it deserves yes they're
aware of the fact that yeah this is
we've done this before and we got to do
something different so again I think
that's kind of where the storytelling in
the exploration are coming from the it
just adds another dimension to the game
that was always kind of present but was
never fully explored so yeah I mean
everything I've seen is the game gives
me faith it will be a worthwhile
experience I'm not saying I'll guarantee
10 out of 10 but at this point there
were no real red flags there's no reason
to believe that it's going to be like a
total mess or anything like that so yeah
I mean I'm fingers crossed it all works
out sweet
you